on retrouve tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial antoine claireaux vous êtes en
direct de john yates comment est-ce
qu'on réagit autour de vous antoine
après cette réunion du conseil de
sécurité où on a entendu beaucoup la
majorité des tous les intervenants à
cette réunion se déclarer favorable à
cette reconnaissance est donc à
l'indépendance des territoires
s'autoproclamer
oui bien avant ça j'aimerais revenir sur
la déclaration qui a qui a commencé un
petit peu caire qui a été fait en amont
de cette réunion du conseil de sécurité
nationale celle du président de la
république autoproclamée de deux nièces
que de nice push chine qui a donc appelé
la russie et le président russe à
reconnaître la république populaire de
données est mais aussi celle de lugan je
vous propose d'écouter de nice pau chine
au nom de l'ensemble du peuple nous vous
demandons de reconnaître la république
populaire de dos n'y est que comme un
état indépendant démocratique de droit
et social nous vous demandons également
d'envisager la possibilité de conclure
un accord d'amitié et de coopération
entre la république populaire de dawn y
est ce qu'est la russie prévoyant une
coopération dans le domaine de la
défense
hier le la semaine dernière déjà le
président de la république autoproclamée
2 days qui avait accueilli favorablement
cette proposition faite par la douma la
chambre basse du parlement russe et bien
d'appeler le président russe à
reconnaître la république populaire de
deux nièces qui est celle de lougansk et
nul doute que la population du dombass
et pas seulement les huit cent mille
citoyens russes qui la composent nul
doute que toute la population attend
maintenant avec impatience la décision
finale de vladimir poutine une décision
qui de toute façon changer beaucoup de
choses pour tous ces gens d'un côté
comme de l'autre et décision de vladimir
poutine attendus dans la soirée merci
beaucoup à antoine frérot